eheleute was geht ab herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video hier auf meinem
zettel mal wieder und zwar habe ich mir
für heute was ganz besonderes überlegt
und zwar sind hier zurzeit diese drei
live oder droh-videos total in und ja
die sind aber schon finde ich ein
bisschen ausgelutscht deswegen hab ich
gleich mal im anderen thema überlegt
fand ich auch extrem viele fragen wie
bis auf youtube bekommen warum machst du
das ganze und bei mir dreht sich dort
alles um meine youtube geschichte also
das video heißt roma youtube story und
ja ich will dann auch nicht ich werde
noch gar nicht lange aber nicht kann ich
so gut malen wir sehen wird aber ich
fange es auch direkt mal an als es fing
alles an ich war glaube ich so elf jahre
alt und war halt oft auf myvideo oder
auch clipfish unterwegs hatte aber noch
keine ahnung von youtube dass das
überhaupt existierten so aber ich war
von diesen videos halt mit elf jahren
dafür dass total witzig habe einfach
über jeden scheiß gelacht und ja von
youtube hatte ich aber wie gesagt
überhaupt keine ahnung und ja mirwald
gar nicht klar dass da noch etwas
vielleicht sogar etwas größeres als
damals myvideo oder clipfish gaben so
dann bin ich eigentlich durch zufall auf
youtube.com und zwar war ich zu dieser
zeit so ein richtiger kleiner hardcore
zocker der sohn browsergame gezeugt hat
ich war so eng fra 12 jahre alt und in
diesem spiel gab es auch später selber
eigentlich ziemlich berühmt aber von dem
also ich wusste auch dass ihn gibt aber
ich wusste dass er ein youtube kanal hat
und von seinem youtube-kanal hier dann
mein kumpel den link geschickt und das
war eigentlich so mein erster kontakt
mit youtube und ja ich fand das
eigentlich alles ziemlich geil dass das
es youtube auch noch gibt und war dann
eigentlich nur auf youtube unterlegt
und diese videos die er da gemacht hat
er mich einfach total inspiriert und da
habe ich mir dann gedacht hey ich finde
einfach geil so was willst du machen und
das habe ich dann auch irgendwie in die
tat umgesetzt ich habe mir dann meinen
ersten eigenen youtube-kanal erstellt
der ist ich weiß ganz auf jeden fall war
der alte solche videos auch von diesem
browsergame bestimmt
ja ich habe meine videos mit movie maker
geschnitten und die waren eigentlich
ziemlich scheiße am anfang so ich wusste
auch überhaupt noch nicht was abonnenten
sind und irgendwann habe ich dann diese
zahl gesehen 26 abonnenten was ist das
überhaupt das ja eigentlich gar nicht
mal so wenig für meine verhältnisse
damals aber ich wusste halt noch nicht
kommt - was vorstellen das sind leute
wie deine freunde oder so und dann habe
ich herausgefunden was es ist da habe
ich mich einfach total gefreut
total gefreut und das war noch mal so
ein punkt der mine spaß folgt hier der
mine spaßfaktor extrem gesteigert hat
und ja leider habe ich dann spaß an
diesen videos verloren ich glaube ich
hatte am ende nur so 30 abonnenten hatte
aber dann noch ein zweites spiel auf
lager was ich auch noch gezeigt habe wie
ich wie schon gesagt ich war so ein
richtiger hardcore zocker das war combat
arms und wir gerade gelesen habt habe
ich da so reviews von waffen gemacht mit
meiner piepsstimme im jahre alt war
ich glaube 12 oder so auf jeden fall man
sieht ich war überhaupt nicht in
stimmung und habe aber irgendwie mein 60
abonnenten geschafft und darauf war ich
auch dann irgendwie stolz aber keine
ahnung
ja ich glaub ich hab dann am ende dieses
sommers also wo ich damit fast aufgehört
habe nochmal so einem live video gemacht
was dann auch relativ gut angekommen ist
und das eigentlich so der startpunkt für
meine sachen die ich heute mache habe
dann auch mit einem kumpel noch einen
account erstellt der heslach einfach die
frau habe ich auch so nach einfach steht
da hab ich auch so unterhaltungs videos
gemacht jetzt mit der wand da aber na ja
auf jeden fall hatten wir da 8000 klicks
und 150 abonnenten erreicht und
irgendwann haben wir dann davon gehört
dass man mit youtube geld verdienen kann
und das war einfach so einen moment mit
seinem hobby geld zu verdienen das wäre
einfach so geil gewesen für uns aber
dann haben wir gemerkt ja mit 8000
klicks verdienst nicht viel vielleicht
zehn euro hätte also nicht gelohnt das
war ziemlich enttäuschend sodann war der
erste neunte 2011 und da habe ich halt
meinen eigenen ersten kanal erstellt und
den hab ich auch direkt blockbuster 1
genannt den kennen wahrscheinlich viele
von euch das war mein alter
und ja weil blockbuster auf switcher so
mit diesem kanal habe ich halt auch wenn
leute schreiben
ich kann nicht mal ich weiß also dass
ein bisschen scheiße aus im endeffekt
hast du schon beim malen gemerkt ich
kann einfach überhaupt nicht zeichnen so
aber egal
mit diesem account aber auch relativ
schnell 100 abos erreicht und das war
nicht auch ziemlich geil aber ich wollte
halt ziemlich oft darauf angesprochen
was machst du da und da habe ich mich
hatte ich dann schon so meine zweifel
ist ein komisches vw oder weiß ich mich
aber ich habe auf jeden fall
durchgehalten und dann hab ich auch
irgendwann meine 500 abonnenten erreicht
habe ich auch wieder extrem stolz und
das war so die zeit da habe ich einfach
kontakt zu so vielen leuten bekommen
wollen zu den lobbys zu wie neon die
hatten damals auch weniger abonnenten
die noch reserven 5000 abonnenten oder
so erst das war einfach so eine
unbeschreiblich geile zeit
julian tim
dennis und mario und überhaupt dabei das
sollte ich wahrscheinlich jetzt diesen
namen das war einfach so keine kollegen
so coole kollegen damals zwei und somit
die ganze zeit ich auf youtube leben
durch firmen im sommer ferien einfach
jeden abend gezeigt und haben uns
einfach kaputt gelacht über
irgendwelchen scheiß sei überhaupt kein
fluss ist also das war extrem lustig und
zeigt welche auch auf jeden fall nie
vergessen
durch die hilfe von diesen von meinen
ganzen ex kollegen oder bzw
ein bisschen kontakt habe ich zudem
immer noch alle hab ich dann auch
schnell die tausend abonnenten erreicht
und das war einfach so ein krasses
gefühl du weißt 1000 leute schauen wir
zu dass einfach auch richtig geil und
von dort an ging es einfach nur noch
bergauf
meine videos ich konnte eigentlich immer
verbessern immer mehr leute haben sich
die angeschaut und jahre hab hier auch
ziemlich schnell meine 2000 abonnenten
erreicht und meine community war einfach
so die geister die ich mir nur
vorstellen konnte
ja das war einfach super geile zeit und
ich war leider so ein vollidiot und habe
das irgendwie alles weggeschmissen ich
weiß gar nicht warum ich kann mir
einfach überhaupt nicht mehr daran
erinnern warum ich diesen diese
entscheidung getroffen habe und ja
irgendwie war dann alles weg und kaum
leute und auch meine videos geschaut
wenn ich dann mal wieder eins
hochgeladen habe also ich hab das alles
so ein bisschen selber schuld
aber dann habe ich mir auch irgendwann
gedacht das kannst dich gewesen seien
youtube hat dein leben sogar ein
bisschen verändert sage ich mal
ja und dann hab ich also neuanfang
geplant weil ich auch extrem motiviert
war
und ja mein anfang der bar so naja ich
habe nicht so viele abonnenten bekommen
vielleicht zu 500 im monat oder so was
ja ein bisschen scheiße ist im vergleich
zueinander aber also zu dem kanal davor
aber schnell habe ich dann auch die
tausend abonnenten erreicht ist hier auf
einem neuen channel und jetzt stehe ich
hier auf 1600 abonnenten es geht immer
schneller wieder
also es freut mich dass ich also dass
ich jetzt wieder die richtige
entscheidung getroffen hat dass sich die
videos wieder mache für euch dass so
viele leute sich die wieder anschauen
das freut mich wirklich extrem und
damals ja auch einfach noch mal danke
sagen an alle leute vor allem die mich
schon seit so vielen jahren unterstützen
was hier auf youtube mache die meine
videos schauen die meine videos licon
die sie vielleicht mal teilen die mir so
viele nachrichten schicken die mir
vielleicht auf instagram folgen und so
weiter also ihr seid einfach dafür dass
es nur also dafür dass es jetzt nicht
mehr so viele wie früher sind sind
trotzdem richtig da merke ich ja da sind
leute dabei die gucken mich schon so
lange und ja das freut mich einfach
total diese bestätigung zu haben dass
leute meine videos gefallen
und ja auf jeden fall danke dafür und
ich hoffe ihr werdet mich noch in
zukunft weiter unterstützen und das war
eigentlich auch schon mein ganzes trauma
youtube story video und ich hoffe
natürlich erst hat euch gefallen so
leute das war jetzt doch leider schon
wieder mit diesen bei youtube story
video und ich hoffe natürlich etappe
sowie mal gefallen und die blutiges
video auf jeden fall mal mit dem daumen
nach oben
wenn es euch nicht ganz so gefallen hat
dann natürlich auch einfach daumen nach
oben geben und mich wird natürlich
freuen wenn ihr diesen raum bei youtube
statement jetzt mal auch mal macht also
bald ihr das macht dann sendet mit den
link einfach mal zu hier auf youtube
oder glaube ich gar nicht mehr hier
einfach auf facebook oder so steht hier
und in der video beschreibung und
mehr brauche ich auch gar nicht sagen
hier unten rechts und links geht's
weiter mit meinen letzten beiden videos
auf jeden fall beides ab abonieren nicht
vergessen wenn die nächste verpassen
wollt und ansonsten sei jedoch könnt ihr
natürlich noch die video beschreibung
abchecken und du ja das war es von mir
drei leute bis zum nächsten video das
kommt am nächsten sonntag und ich würde
sagen